hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Section seven of the introduction to
his work being in time Martin Heidegger
is going to introduce us to the concept
not just the vague general idea but the
concept of phenomenology as he is
interpreting it and in the process of
doing so he's going to clarify for us
what is meant by phenomenon and it'll be
very helpful if you don't automatically
try to associate Heidegger with other
versions of phenomenology that you may
have encountered or with a sort of naive
understanding of phenomenon that doesn't
actually fit into his typology but which
we should talk about and we will a
little bit later on Heidegger is
interested in clarifying for us
what is phenomenon what are phenomena
what is the object of this discipline
that he is going to be engaging in or
rather inquiry and he goes back to the
Greeks saying phenomenon or final mannan
is coming from this this verb finest eye
which is in the middle voice if you
don't understand what that means
it's neither active nor passive but in a
certain sense both and concerned with
itself in this case it's not something
that we use in English but it is
recognized in other indo-european
languages finest i as a verb means
something like to show oneself or to
show itself to reveal to manifest itself
and so as he tells us the phenomena are
the things that actually show themselves
to us he also you know engages a little
bit more etymology that we can skip over
so he tells us that the the meaning of
the expression phenomenon is established
as what shows itself in itself
what shows itself that's a key part but
in itself not just in the other ways
that we're going to talk about here but
as what it is how it is it reveals
itself in its core to us or to other
things as well so he goes on and he says
these phenomena are thus the totality of
what lies in the light of day or can be
brought to light sometimes as he points
it out the Greeks just identified this
with beings tanta the things that are in
existence that have being right and
beings you said can show themselves from
themselves in various ways there's not
one single modality by which all beings
show themselves to us but they do all
have this property or activity or a
relation to us of displaying finest they
showing themselves in themselves he goes
on and he brings up a second important
modality that we might take as being
connected with the notion of phenomenon
right
he says the possibility even exists that
they can show themselves as they are not
in themselves so things can not only
show themselves the way they are but
they can also show us show themselves to
us in ways that they aren't he calls
this you know in in German shinin we
translate this as seeming or semblance
and he wants to say listen this is
actually founded or established that the
possibility for this is established on
this more primordial self showing the
the very fact and something that
something can show itself to us in a way
that we might consider to be somewhat
deceptive or concealing or
you know leaving something out or
presenting itself in a way that it's not
means that we actually do have some
degree of access to how things in fact
are so he says you know what's an
example of this fine omen and Agathon in
in greek means a you know a good that
looks like but in reality is not what
itself what it gives itself out to be
what would be an example of this well in
ancient Greek philosophy pleasure is
often a fine omen and August August on
right so is wealth the apparent good
it's not truly good I mean it could be
good for something that's the useful
good right but it's easy to mix it up
because pleasure imposes itself on us
and you know seduces us cajoles us and
then you know after it swirled us around
leaves us feeling kind of empty as a
result so what seems semblance he goes
on and he says you know these are both
connected with each other
the original meaning phenomenon what is
manifest already contains and is the
basis of the second meaning phenomenon
semblance so he says we attribute to the
term phenomenon the positive and
original meaning of phenomenon
terminologically and separate the
phenomenon assemblance from it as a
privat of modification what does that
mean that so that's a little bit of
technical language that we use in
philosophy particularly in metaphysics
for those who have a basis in it in its
history a privation is where there is a
lack of what ordinarily or ought to be
there so blindness is a privation of
sight it's not merely a opposite of it
it's a definite lack now Heidegger is
going to go further here he's going to
introduce two more
categories you could say and now he's
going to talk about appearance instead
of it being seeming shinin it's going to
be appearance air shinin he's making a a
distinction there and he says that
phenomenon is often used of appearances
as well he says what both of these
original terms Express has at first
nothing to do with what's called
appearance or even mere appearance which
have a big role in philosophy so he says
one speaks of for example and he's using
some a case here the appearances or
symptoms of an illness of a Cronkite's
right a illness within the body or the
mind and he says what is meant by this
are occurrences within the body that
show themselves so they are presenting
themselves to us but how are they
presenting themselves they are
presenting themselves as of something
else something that as Heidegger is
going to point out they indicate
something that does not show itself so
for example certain bodily symptoms
signify or indicate they are the
appearances of a fever can you actually
see the fever you could say well I can
feel the fever when I have it yes that
that's quite true but Heidegger is
talking about you seeing or perceiving
or in some way grasping the fever of the
other person he says appearance says
they what lies behind the appearances in
these in these cases doesn't actually
show itself in these ways so he goes on
and he says when such occurrences emerge
their self showing concedes with the
objective presence for honden sign being
out there for us you know of
disturbances that don't show themselves
appearance as the appearance of
something he says thus precisely does
not mean that something shows itself
it means something makes itself known
which does not show itself so that's a
very important distinction there
something makes itself known which does
not show itself to us the ones who are
you know grasping it now of course the
thing that's functioning as the
appearance does show itself to us so if
we're talking about the flush or the
hotness the clam enos those are things
that show themselves what this means for
Heidegger is that appearance remains
founded upon the more primordial
conception of phenomenon right so he
goes on and he says what does not show
itself in the manner of what appears can
also never seem so it's neither of these
the thing that's lurking behind there he
says all indications presentation
symptoms and some symbols have this
fundamental formal structure of
appearance though they differ among
themselves there's a heterogeneity to
them so he says appearing is only
possible on the basis of a self showing
of something the the thing that's
appearing that's indicating has to be
self showing but it's you might say
gesturing towards something more
important something that is supposed to
be lying behind it revealed through it
but isn't revealed through it so he says
the concept of phenomenon is not going
to be delimited by this but rather
presupposed now why does he say that
because many people in the history of
Western metaphysics end up taking
appearance or even what we're going to
talk about his mere appearance as if
those are the paradigm for phenomena and
this is going to be a fundamental
problem in heidegger's view
he says appearance in the way that we
normally use it so here's we have to
take a little pause from our categories
here can have a double meaning appearing
in the sense of making itself known as
something that does not show itself so
this technical meaning of appearance is
he
using it second in the sense of what
does the making itself known the thing
that's doing the appearance saying we
could say he says finally one can use
appearing as the term for the genuine
meaning of phenomenon as self showing
and if we mix these three up he says
we're gonna wind up in all sorts of
confusions so we need to keep these
distinct in our analysis from each other
now let's talk about mere appearance he
says appearance can take on yet another
fourth a category within the schema
second meaning of its own
he says if one understands what does the
making itself known what what is
supposed to be behind the appearance
right what in itself showing indicates
the non manifest as what comes to the
fore in the non manifest itself and
radiates from it in such a way that what
is non manifest is thought of as what is
essentially never manifest so this is
very complicated way of talking here
right what does he have in mind
something like the con Sheehan thing in
itself the noumenon right behind the
phenomenon he says if this is so that
appearance is tantamount to production
here for bringing in German and he says
or to what is produced here for Galactus
these are correlative terms right here
for bringing what is being brought out
in front of us so let's think about how
this would make sense and what he has in
mind here when we talk about things that
were encountering here in the phenomenal
world the world of appearances the way
that we ordinarily talk about this as
being produced by things that we never
really could see sense perhaps not even
truly understand then we have this mere
appearances notion at play this is very
strong in conscience fee
but it comes out of the ways in which
both rationalist and empiricist
philosophy and the time before can't
we're understanding the relation of the
knowing and acting subject in relation
to the world that they were involved in
and encountering so he goes down
underneath says what dot what does the
making itself known and is brought
forward shows itself in such a way that
as the emanation of what it makes known
it precisely and continually veils what
it is in itself but then again this not
showing which veils is not semblance
Conti says uses that the term appearance
in this twofold way on the one hand
appearances are the objects of empirical
intuition what were what were what's
appearing to us right on the other
he says appearance as the emanation of
something that makes itself known
but conceals itself in its appearance so
now we have four different categories of
things that fall under the phenomena all
of these three are in fact ultimately
based in one way or another upon the
more primordial conception of that which
is actually showing itself in itself but
this unfortunately gets lost and as time
goes on we tend more and more towards
thinking in these terms and thereby
misunderstand what phenomena or
phenomena is supposed to be so he goes
on and he tells us a few other things in
this section says if in the way we grasp
the concept of phenomenon we leave
undetermined which beings are to be
addressed as phenomena and we leave
altogether open whether the self showing
is a particular being or a
characteristic of the being of beings
then we're dealing solely with the
formal concept of the phenomenon if
we're thinking in very generic terms
might say although generic is actually
the wrong way to say it because being is
not a genus right he says what already
shows itself in appearances prior to and
always accompanying what we commonly
understand is phenomena can be brought
the matically to self showing and this
is indeed what phenomenology in
Heidegger's sense is supposed to do it's
not only supposed to show us individual
things or their relations but it's
supposed to show us what goal was
ontologically beyond that so he mentions
for example space and time
which are two of the the key aspects of
this work being in time-space reality
temporality these can be brought to the
level of phenomenon not in the sense of
any of these but as what shows itself in
itself
so hopefully this clarifies what it is
that Heidegger has in mind as phenomenon
I mentioned that we do also need to
think about something that he doesn't
address in this book because we use this
word phenomenon in a very offhand way in
our own time you know if we talk about a
person is a phenomenon or something is
an internet phenomenon what are we
talking about in here does that fit into
these these four categories or types of
things that might be called phenomena or
do we have something even more vague in
mind like what we ought to be paying
attention to what has importance what
draws our attention what we have to ask
when somebody is using the word
phenomenon is is there something being
revealed or indicated or shown or
signified so if somebody is an internet
phenomenon we should ask ourselves what
does that actually
what are they signifying what does the
person using that term mean to tell us
or to show to us in so speaking and I
leave that up to you to think about
where that might fit in here if indeed
it does Heidegger just to stress this is
primarily concerned with this first more
primordial way of understanding
phenomenon and the seeming that arises
out of it
primitively but sort of so to speak at
just one distance of remove
you